One note of caution,
always be careful.
It's important to check all the sources.
They might not be giving you the full picture,
or they might have made,
you know, an innocent mistake.
So you need to be careful.
Only use those sources that you trust.
Are they likely to have accurate
information on the story?
How much checking do you need to do?
Depends on the type of source,
but it's usually a good idea to check the information
with at least two different sources.
That's our policy.
So we have truth and accuracy,
two of the BBC's basic news values.
The audience need to trust you,
and that depends on you being accurate.
They're important values,
and they'll help you become not just a reporter,
but a trusted school reporter.
Uh, one more important bit of advice.
To protect people under the age of 18,
you must only use their first names in reports.
Never use surnames.
Okay, that's a good policy, too.
So good luck finding the new stories,
have fun, and we'll talk again.